creo que en su relevante pero no se
puede comparar como dijo el doctor en el
bar las acciones del presidente y trump
fue con contra las elecciones las
instituciones demócratas
del de los eeuu y dentro del mismo
capitolio ahora muestra para mí que los
seguidores de trump y la mayoría de
publicanos tienen otro óptica y es
emblemático de la población política en
su mundo a donald trump es la víctima y
donald trump ha sido perseguido desde
que ganó las elecciones en el 2016 y los
demócratas han intentado tumbar los
desde ese momento entonces esa es una
continuación de que yo no trampas y dos
víctimas no sólo de los demócratas sino
de los medios de los élites políticas y
ese alimento en su base alimentar la
rabia de su pase
ahora es claro que estamos hoy también
en un juicio político y no en un juicio
jurídico que signifique eso ya sabemos
que es casi imposible que van a votar
para condenarlo porque los republicanos
no lo van a permitir y es una cuestión
política que estamos examinando las
bulos votos políticos ya están allí para
apoyar donald trump entonces esa defensa
es muy previsible ellos van a argumentar
que es una ecuación de libre expresión
es una cuestión de persecución y que él
no hizo nada y donald trump como un gran
comunicador que el invento de sus
palabras es difícil capturarlo diciendo
que habrá violencia aunque como hemos
visto los últimos días casi todos los
seguidores estaban actuando bajo lo que
ellos pensaban eran las instrucciones de
doctor su comportamiento no se puede
defender pero no creo que va a ser
suficiente
una condena en este juicio político